how did i get started
so i got a great question from one of my
readers dennis love you guys
dennis wrote in to me he's on my
newsletter list and i wrote in to say
evan you didn't tell me how you got
started with what you're doing man
so would you care to tell me a short
tale on that dude
dennis thanks for the question so
quick story all put together when i was
in university i had job offers from
companies that i thought would be
awesome to work with a couple years ago
and i felt like i wanted to better
myself and just try my own business
and i had a biotech software company
with two friends and
we struggled at the beginning i was
making nothing
uh and we turned it around and in a
couple years i got the company acquired
and my partners went to california as
part of the deal and i stayed here
and that's when i
i struggled to figure out what i'm going
to do next you know i'm like i'm in my
early 20s
i had the success with this company i
didn't want to go
get a job but i didn't have a burning
idea for what to do with my next company
and i've always been a big believer
that if you're not sure what you want to
do next
you don't have a burning passion for
anything yet go out and explore
try stuff and a lot of it won't work
and you get a sense of that pretty
quickly and some of it will stick and
you'll love it and opportunities will
come from that
don't try to force an idea i don't know
that's hard like that was me i'm like i
want to do something now i got to figure
this out now
you know i'd always had an interest in
venture capital i never needed it for my
business but i wanted to learn about it
so uh through a connection i ended up
with
a position at a venture capital company
in toronto helping companies raise half
a million to 15 million dollars for
companies
and i learned how the process worked and
i connected with
the three founders who were all in their
60s or 70s and had all the experience in
the world
and i had a position with them as a
associate wasn't wasn't a formal
employee relationship i could still do
whatever i wanted
but i helped bring in deals and i
learned the process because i wanted to
learn about it
i didn't think this would be a long-term
thing for me but it was something i was
curious about
at the same time i was i was in the
media a lot i was asked to speak at
events
because i was a young entrepreneur sold
the business had that success
and my first speaking gig
in toronto was at the ymca they had a
group of entrepreneurs who were
i think fired or laid off from their
jobs and they want to start their own
company as a way to
create their own path for themselves and
so
i said sure be happy to come and speak
and share my lessons and what i've
learned i'd love to help
and i spent a lot of time figuring out
everything i wanted to say and all the
things that i had learned through my
failure and then success
and i remember the day came when i was
promoting it for two weeks to my
you know friends in circles and and the
ymca was pointing it to their audience
and i spent so much time on this concept
the presentation and i was nervous you
know i wanted to be perfect
and i you know come up on that day i
remember going through the doors and my
heart's beating i'm starting to sweat
like oh my god it's coming i've been
working so hard for this moment
and i go up with this huge room ready to
go
tons of chairs and i walk into the room
open the door
and i just sink for a minute because
after all of this work three people
showed up to listen to me
i was like wow like i was promoting this
for two weeks and the ymca was pointing
it to their audience and they had a
student base already who was interested
in this
and i felt like such a failure you know
like
i spent all this time on something and
for a free event and i
can only get three people to come out
and
that was a big turning point for me
because
i could have given a crappy presentation
and
and felt like this wasn't for me and
tried something else
but what i discovered was i was there we
had three people like i'm gonna i did
all this work on the presentation so i'm
gonna make it the best presentation
these three people have ever seen
and it ended up being amazing and those
people were changed that day
and i felt the way
that i had to keep doing this it felt so
natural felt so amazing such a high
helping these people out and changing
their lives that i felt like i had to
keep going and doing this even though
anybody who looked at this would have
said evan you're crazy like
you want to turn this into a business
you this is going to be your thing now
you can't get more than three people to
come to a free event man what are you
doing this is stupid
and by all logical
reasoning it was right it was it was
stupid to think that i could turn this
into a business
and yet i loved it and so i knew i had
to find a way to keep going and if you
talk to successful entrepreneurs that's
what you'll often find is they love
what they did so much that they had to
find a way to keep going
and people would do it even if they
weren't getting paid because they loved
it so much like i
love helping entrepreneurs and i do a
lot of it without getting paid just
because it
brings me happiness and then i found a
way to turn it into
a business eventually right it wasn't i
wish i said i had this whole plan worked
out like i
sat down and i wrote my plan and this is
how it's going to work
i had i didn't have a plan you know i
was following my passion and tried to
find
something that would take me in a
direction that i would enjoy doing
and it turned from the speaking into
my website that i used to say where i
was speaking and then people
started asking could they share content
on there
i said sure you can write an article for
my website this is the time before
article marketing was anything
people wanted just to be on my site and
i use it as lead generation for
the venture capital business that i was
part of and i started talking about
modeling the masters and i started
talking about how to raise capital
put those articles up there realizing i
could sell advertising
against that and then started making
money from advertising it was a little
side thing on
just whatever just something i was
having some fun with
and then more and more people started
writing in to me and saying we want to
know more about your story we want to
know more about
what got you here and your advice and at
that time
everything was behind the scenes for me
i was always sharing stories of famous
entrepreneurs and their success and
showing examples but not too much about
my story
and i was shocked like why do people
care about my story
so i started sharing it more and more
you know my face wasn't even on the home
page
and so it got more and more me telling
my story and then i got invited to do
more speaking and
and then i started my youtube channel
and and social media and twitter and all
that stuff and it's it's built it's
built into this
amazing community right every video i
put up we get comments we get views and
get subscribers
i love it like the best part of my day
now is being
i wake up in the morning i grab my bowl
of lentils and i go to the computer and
look at the comments that i get from
youtube and my social media channels i
love that stuff
and it all came out of following
what i love doing having the courage to
not know where i'm going and just
explore things
and when i found something that i really
like to do even though it made no sense
to continue doing it
i continued on and found a way to turn
it into a business
and something that i'm still passionate
about i don't know 12 years later
11 years later 12 years still whatever
it doesn't matter still passionate about
it
so that's my story i don't know
hopefully that helps give you some
inspiration or helps answer your
question
let me know what you guys think you know
if you want more videos like this
leave a comment below let me know what
other questions you have i'm happy to do
a video
for you if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up
click on my face there subscribe to the
channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon